my name is Matt Walsh I'm here as a
husband father and concerned citizen of
the state of Tennessee and I want to
thank the committee for allowing me to
speak and for all of you on the
committee who support this important
legislation
now I know that we can't agree on very
much these days but we should be able to
agree that our most solemn
responsibility as individuals as a state
and as a country is to protect our
children we should be able to agree that
children do not have the physical
emotional or mental capacity to protect
themselves or to make life-altering
decisions
we should be able to agree that it's
never okay to chemically castrate
sterilized butcher or mutilate a child
and in fact all decent people do agree
on all these points but many of the
people hold power in this country and
who run our institutions including our
medical institutions do not pass this
basic test of decency